venezuela's are dying in huge amounts
venezuela was once the richest country
in latin america it still has the
world's biggest oil reserves but 20
years ago that is Whelan's voted for
socialism they elected Hugo Chavez some
Americans were excited about that model
Naomi Campbell visited Chavez calling
him a rebel angel this is you and Hugo
most important forces we've had on this
planet and even today as Venezuela
collapses many Americans say don't blame
socialism actually blaming socialism for
Venezuela's riches-to-rags story is
grossly misleading
yes Manas whele is going through an
insane political crisis right now but
it's not clear that that crisis has
anything to do with their socialist
policies this popular video the collapse
of Venezuela explained never once
mentioned socialism oil prices plummeted
in 2014 and Maduro failed to adjust
media personalities suggest only
conservatives say socialism destroyed
Venezuela if you follow conservative
media at all you might have seen it
frequently painted as the inevitable
dire consequences of a socialist
government the problem isn't socialism
since John Oliver it's a story about
epic mismanagement but mismanagement is
what happens under socialist governments
it always happens because no group of
central planners is wise enough to
manage an entire economy even if they
have good intentions the socialists
eventually run out of other people's
money the socialist solution then is to
print more that caused massive inflation
the nation's failed economy is expected
to hit 10 million percent inflation this
year when business owners raise prices
to keep up with inflation government
often took away their businesses yeah
cheffy CEO
put on PSA this man just had his
business take socialists say government
can run businesses better than greedy
owners who just want profit and even
though that led to tyranny in Venezuela
and China and Russia Korea Vietnam
Cambodia Cuba there are plenty of
socialist countries that look nothing
like Venezuela when I talk about
democratic socialism I'm not looking at
Venezuela I'm not looking at Cuba I'm
looking at countries like Denmark and
Sweden oh yes those countries do have
bigger welfare programs that America
does but they are not socialist they
make a point of saying that here's
Denmark's Prime Minister Denmark is far
from socialist plant economy Denmark is
a market economy not only that lately
they've reduced government control of
their economy they privatized the
national phone system and the railroads
and they sold Copenhagen Airport to a
private company it's the same story in
Sweden if we did have a period in the
1970s and 1980s when we had something
that resembled socialism big government
that taxed and spend heavily and that's
the period in Swedish history when our
economy was going south so Sweden
reduced government's role to they even
instituted school choice the
Scandinavian countries that progressives
call socialist successes not only are
they not socialist they're moving more
toward capitalism the silver lining in
Venezuela's collapse is that most
Venezuelans who escape their country's
socialism do understand what went wrong
in Florida reporter Gloria Alvarez asked
Venezuelan immigrants why do you think
about socialism that doesn't work so no
salary common area anayia it's not gonna
work it never gonna work do you think
that people once they get out of
Venezuela do they understand that the
problem is socialism I think that
great percentage of them do your problem
is a socialist system that they tried to
make work but that has never worked and
will never work it will never work as
Ludwig von Mises wrote the champions of
socialism promised the Garden of Eden
but planned to transform the world into
a gigantic post office every man
subordinate clerk
I wish progressives understood that
since they don't tragedies like
Venezuela will happen again and again